but ultimate success means avoiding  burnout and designing a life that aligns  with your values over an extended period  of time and i think now is the best time  to  get clear on what that might look like  and lay the foundation for that just  embrace the idea that you're at the  beginning of a very long journey and  within that you can kind of relax and  prioritize self-care is important and  valuable but not to confuse that with  laziness because you will have to work  hard but i think that hard work should  come within the context of a strategy  that relates to playing the long game  like you can work hard and you can take  care of yourself they're not necessarily  mutually  exclusive or orthogonal ideas